i liked when joe rogan came out and he
said look i'm going to stop talking to
politicians because i don't want to be a
player in this field
and when it comes to this stuff that
we're talking about i don't want to be a
player in that so if the government is
coming and taking your rights away and
saying if you don't take the vaccine
we're going to fire you from the job i'm
going to stand up and say that's wrong
well right if the government is forcing
you to wear a nappy on your face it
doesn't work right
yeah you're going to stay i'm going to
stand up and say that's wrong if the
government is forcing you to live in a
quarantined facility when you have a
disease that is akin to flu i'm going to
stand up and say that wrong but all of
this other stuff it becomes a little bit
above my pay grade is my point and
that's why
i think uh you know you talked earlier
about sort of like well this is a
problem you you don't feel capable
solving so you solve the ones that you
can actually i do think that's a recipe
for for a sane person in my opinion
there are many many things i could worry
about in the world on which i have
absolutely no impact
and on which my
interference will probably make things
worse rather than better and rather than
focusing my energies on that my energy
is limited i'm going to focus on
fighting for the things that i do
understand that i do think are important
and that i can make a difference on and
that's what i've been doing so
this is not me rejecting what you're
saying this is not me taking a position
either way and either mectin or vaccines
or anything like that all i'm saying is
i think the time for people like me
interfering in things like public health
policy is at an end
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i have the great pleasure today
of sitting in person with constantine
kissin i am sitting of course on his set
the set of trigonometry also known
affectionately as trigger pod welcome
constantine thanks very much it's great
to have you here in london and for us to
sit down in person it is great to sit
down in person last time i saw you was
pre-covered yes it was yeah uh so it's
been some time and the world is a new
place yes since last we spoke in person
thank you for the loan of this set
i will say i'm concerned about one thing
which is that um because all of the
visuals here are your visuals i'm
triggered to just let you ask questions
that's not going to work is it well it's
a pity because we would have loved to
have you back on the show and in person
but uh francis so as people may know
i've been on paternity leave and francis
has been on holiday or
very much needed one the last couple of
weeks while i've been dealing with the
new baby so that's why we're not able to
interview because he's still abroad uh
but i i'm really pleased that we get a
chance to chat anyway yeah me too and um
i don't know how much it will be a focus
of our discussion but the new baby is
certainly the most important fact in the
room here at the moment and
congratulations
i'm really enjoying it actually uh and
you and i were talking earlier before we
started and i was kind of
you know not complaining but sort of
saying like the baby's at the stage
where he's you know just he does a lot
of poops and he does a lot of sucking on
my wife's breasts and that's about it
really at this point uh so but i'm
really enjoying it anyway but it's not
quite at the stage where they have a
personality yet so i'm really looking
forward to getting to that point where
you actually get to meet the person
so at the point that you have stopped
producing new children you kind of
forget some of what goes on am i right
that your child is still in the stage
where they remain where you leave them
yes oh yeah yeah he's only about 12 days
old oh so you can't even roll over no
rollover maybe is about no no no still
not still not yeah pooing eating
screaming if those two things are in the
wrong setting and that's about it you
know if you're going to count on your
fingers the things that the child does
you're going to find a phase where
you're going to run out of digits and
you have to count some other way but
um anyway it is
um i
i would just say it is transformative
when you have a child because it
rearranges the whole logic of life i
can't even figure out exactly what words
to say except that this is
um the way in which the human purpose
unfolds and we many people
don't have children and they have found
new purposes and all of that's marvelous
but at the point that you return
to this
sacred role of
passing on what you are to this new
human in this very special way that
humans do it it can't help really but
transform really everything about life
and
i do hear what you're saying i went
through the same thing where
at first
you know babies are you know a really
important fact and you feel the
emotional bond that you feel but it's
like well you know i
i can't really father the child very
well at this point because you know uh
they're
they're just not capable of taking on
the kinds of lessons that i'm equipped
to teach um but
you'll be there so soon oh my i'm loving
the whole process as it is i'm just i
was just observing that uh it's it's
there's a kind of transitional phase but
in terms of the point that you make
about it changing who you are and how
you view the world and how you behave i
noticed it literally the day that i
found out my wife was pregnant i was
driving into london here uh to the
studio and uh a guy cut me up and sort
of blocked me off on the road and he was
completely in the wrong by the rules of
the road and normally in that situation
i'm not gonna lie i i am
i if people are going to behave like a
dick i am going to make it uncomfortable
for them to continue to behave that way
usually so i would normally take extra
time to you know i wouldn't be screaming
and shouting i'd take extra time to get
out of his way make sure i was extra
slow
give him an extra smile he would make
sure there was no profit in his behavior
right the behavior would shut itself
yeah exactly thank you for for giving an
evolutionary spin to me being a dick
so basically that's what i would
normally do and the that day i just
found out my wife was pregnant i had
absolutely no it's not that i decided to
be a different person
i just noticed that i had absolutely no
emotional reaction and i just let this
guy get on with it as quickly as he
could didn't make it any more difficult
and i just think
um
there is something that definitely
happened with me
which
in terms of how i conceive of myself in
in the society that i existed in terms
of my status and in relation to other
people and what i'm trying to achieve in
the world instantly changed uh about
about that time when i realized there's
a person who's now
counting on me
in a way that even my wife
wasn't counting my wife will be fine
without me
i would hope
but a little baby won't and i think that
that switch of being responsible for
another human being who's
helpless without you
uh you change the way i think and behave
about myself and i'm sure there's quite
a lot that you could probably talk to me
about in terms of the evolutionary
function of preserving yourself versus
being a young male and risk taking and
all of that
well i remember uh a similar
shocking
transition it wasn't on discovering that
heather was pregnant it was i believe
the night before she gave birth to my
first child zach
and i remember i think this must have
been triggered by a dream which i don't
remember
but i remember feeling my brain rewire
around the concept that the right thing
to do would involve
you know running into the burning
building to save this person were it
necessary right i remember that
transition and it was like and it
happened close enough to consciousness
that i would you know i wouldn't be of
two minds about it right
now here's the really uncomfortable part
though
the logic changes at the point that you
have a second child
right
because
one does not want to take
the tiniest chance
right of saving
and a jeopardized child if it is going
to strand another child so that there's
an equation that that has to be built
and i remember that transition from this
is now a very simple thing even a very
small chance of saving this person is
worth trading your life over right to
well you have to figure out the costs
and benefits which you know frankly i
wish i didn't have that piece of
information it's uncomfortable to know
that that calculation is taking place
but
i did feel it and you know yeah it sure
does line up with the evolutionary logic
fascinating fascinating well it's i i
think uh
it sounds so cheesy and in modern
society you're not supposed to say it
but i it is a revolutionary experience
it changes your view of things entirely
it does now i i will give you some
advice that you definitely didn't ask
for please
there is i believe
no way
to properly raise a child in this era
that ship has sailed the era is so
screwed up and the um the hazards are so
many and they're growing at such a rate
that
um if i were you i would just
you know
the cheering message every father needs
to hear well but here's the thing you
need to know it because
um until you i mean maybe this is
different for you maybe you've seen
enough parenting but in our case heather
and i hadn't seen any real parenting
either we had seen the parenting that
was done for us but we hadn't been
around a lot of parents at the point we
had kids and
um so we learned a lot of lessons uh
just by trial and error and talking it
out
um but
one has the sense right we know that bad
parenting
messes kids up right and so there's a
you know if you're if you're good at the
job of parenting you'll be very
concerned that you don't want to do that
right
but what what is harder to understand is
how resilient
the child is to bad parenting so the
point is you'll make plenty of errors
and the child is
seeking um signal in noise so if your
parenting is basically good then the
child will get the result of good
parenting as a result of you know
they'll throw out the outlying bad
parenting stuff that you do and they'll
get the good message the problem is that
things are changing so rapidly and so
many of the things that you're
interfacing with
it's hard to to know whether the novelty
of them is a hazard or not
that um
i don't think it's really
possible to deliver your kid a program
that will make them
you know a happy healthy well-adjusted
adult because well adjusted to what
exactly to a world in chaos yeah sure i
think that's probably always has been
true to a large extent i mean there
would have been periods of time when it
would have been easier to prepare your
child for the future because the future
was unlikely to change
uh as much as it's changing now but
there have been other periods in human
history i think where technological
change has caused the sort of rapid
transformation of society that we're
seeing now
um
and i i also you know i'm not i'm not
determined
that i i am the perfect parent i know
that's not possible i am quite keen to
be a better parent than my parents were
to me or than my wife's parents were to
her
and i sort of think like that's that's a
likely outcome uh to be honest you know
i love my parents and they did their
best but when i was born my mom was
she'd been 18 for four days my dad was
20 and they didn't know what the hell
they were doing um so if i can and i've
turned out in my head all right
so if i can be better than that i think
my kids will be okay uh and also i just
think
you know i i i maybe quibble with the
idea that it was ever possible to
prepare your children for the future and
maybe this is part of my background you
know i grew up in late soviet union
as a kid and then i saw that world
collapse and almost everybody in that
society
99 of the people in that society were
completely maladapted to the society
that formed overnight
and
so to me the idea that it's actually
possible to genuinely prepare your kids
fully for the future i think it's
probably more about instilling a set of
values in a set of principles
and then they're gonna have to use their
talents and their ingenuity and to fend
for themselves in a way so i think it's
more about you know there's a certain
set of red lines that we don't cross and
there's a certain set of things that we
do do in every circumstance which is you
know we speak the truth when we can
etc etc right all of those things um and
then you just leave them to it i think i
i don't i don't know that you you're
gonna get them to to be well adjusted to
any world because the world's constantly
changing well but the problem is that's
actually new right and i i take your
point about it what about the printing
press i mean that transformed society
i'm still uncertain about it
but look
uh first of all
centuries of violent revolutions around
the world well but here's here's the the
thing that i think is is missing from
this
recent human history has had many of
these violent upheavals and i agree
every single one of those takes people
who were adapted to something and throws
them into some world they don't know
okay
humans are adapted to that and in fact i
would argue that the what we understand
about ptsd tells us that human beings
are uh adapted to make exactly one
violent transition in a lifetime right
and that you know when a soldier comes
back from war is when they have their
problem right you can go from
walking around a normal stable
civilization to being in a jungle and
not knowing whether you're going to step
into a booby trap or somebody a sniper
is going to pick you off you can adapt
to that reality but it's very hard
to turn off the part of your mind that
learned that you could be in such a
circumstance right and so then from then
on every supermarket is like where are
the booby traps and who might you know
who's gonna shoot at me
um so i do think we're built for violent
transitions but one of them what we are
not built for
is
a treadmill
where we are constantly facing
they're not quite as violent but we are
caught i mean if you think about the
difference between this world and the
world pre-coveted in the world
pre-facebook right we keep going through
these violent transitions
and what's more it's like
a treadmill on which some diabolical
force is turning up the speed of it
right the rate at which these violent
transitions are coming at us is going up
and so i don't think there's any way to
be
well we can be well adjusted to change
we can't be well adjusted to
accelerating change with this much at
stake um but
your basic point i think is true which
is if your child is going to face that
world and you know that your child will
then you fall back to something else and
i actually
um
we don't know each other all that well
but i've certainly watched a lot of your
podcast i have a pretty good sense of
who you are and i'm
very confident in your capacity to do
this because
you are
highly conscious and very decent right
your values are good but it's the highly
conscious thing consciousness is the
tool that we have for dealing with
novelty
and you've got it in spades so
you know yeah your kid's going to face
some stuff but um having having a parent
who has modeled that way of approaching
it is about the best thing that they
could have well i appreciate that thank
you i you know
[Music]
i am troubled by some as you well know i
mean this wouldn't exist if i wasn't
troubled by many of the things that are
happening in the modern world but i also
i think
i i've written a book called an
immigrant love letter to the west and i
talk about this stuff a lot in the book
i i go to russia i go to ukraine i speak
to my grandmother in ukraine she's alive
today 96 or maybe pushing 97 years old
now you go talk to you know she's
perfectly accomplished and she lived
through
the
holiday more
the gulags exile nazi occupation
and on and on is the late soviet union
the transition from soviet communism to
modern
society the way it is now the the rapid
advancement of technology this is in one
lifetime
and
is my kid gonna face as many problems as
that i hope not and i don't know that
they will frankly you know uh living
through the several
like several events that have killed
millions of people in your country uh a
foreign invasion with genocidal maniac
who's doing that
those are things that um
may happen again
uh but they may not uh so
i think we get a little i i know the
change of the the pace of change
feels very very difficult at the moment
and i and i think the direction of
travel
has not been good
but i also think that we ought not to
get carried away because
i look at look at comedy for example i
don't do stand-up comedy anymore but
this was how i came into this world uh
of of the conversations we're having and
it's the pendulum is swinging back now
in the comedy world it went from you
know my heroes growing up with people
like george carlin and bill hicks and
they were pushing back
lefties pushing back against the
religion of their day which was religion
right and that's why they made fun of
christians and all of that
we have a new religion now and a few of
us early on started to push back against
that religion and we got the same lumps
we had to take the same lumps that
comedians before us had and now i start
to see the mainstream of the comedy
world very slowly but pivoting back
towards realizing that if you want to be
on the edge if you want to be
exciting then you actually are going to
have to start addressing this new uh
cultist that we've developed so the
pendulum will always swing i am troubled
by the direction that it's been going
i'm also very optimistic bro and maybe
this is just fatherhood speaking through
me and i have to be optimistic for the
future now i don't know but i am
i am less concerned than i've been in
the last five or six years now than i
have been ever personally well i'm
thrilled to hear that because although i
vehemently disagree with you
i uh i think it's a very important data
point in other words if i'm trying to
calibrate my own model how confident am
i in what i'm seeing
i know that you see things from a
different perspective i know you have a
toolkit that was built under very
different circumstances and it's great
to hear that you're optimistic i hope
you're right yeah
and i will say i had a lovely
conversation with neil oliver a couple
days ago and he said something that
upgraded my model quite a bit right
i was talking to him about the
trajectory that i see which is
frankly
quite alarming and dark
and he told me that he thought
that it had been so long since
the major tragedies of history the
events you refer to in which millions
died in particular places
and he said that he thought that because
the current generation of tyrants
is too far removed from that to have
experienced it directly that they've
lost the ability to engage in that level
of wet work
and i must say i found something
compelling about his formulation now i
don't
it doesn't bring me all the way to a
hopeful state because i think
you know i i know it's not going to go
step right if you think that it's going
to go step into the room you're gonna
miss it when it does
arrive because it's learned the lesson
that it mustn't um but
i also think that we are
we are in an existential battle
that existential battle looks nothing
like the battles of the past many of the
tools are strangely reminiscent of the
tools of the past right the the degree
to which orwell is on target is almost
ridiculous
right you know ministries of truth and
you know mal information these
couldn't be more orwellian if they tried
but nonetheless i don't think it's going
to look like those past tragedies
but um it also
well let's take just take one example
just to put some flesh on the bones
there is a battle
to prevent change right those who have
a disproportionate amount some of which
will have been earned through innovation
most of which will have been earned
through rent seeking or worse
those people always have an interest in
thwarting change that they do not
control
right because change can only reduce
their position and their power
so they oppose change right
what does one need to do to successfully
oppose change well in the past you might
need to go after
huge numbers of people right the stasi
had to keep track of an incredibly large
number of people and so it needed
basically to you know to
conscript your neighbors into spying on
you
this thing has tools that the stasi
didn't have right so for example
the ability to gather
everything that we exchange
electronically and bank it in utah right
what that allows them to do is it allows
them not to pay attention to what you're
saying and then at the point that you
become annoying they can say well let's
look at everything you said in the last
10 years what's the what's the most
troubling thing the person said i call
this retroactive surveillance
right and so what it means
is that the thing can leave most people
alone and it only has to exert pressure
on the tiny number of people who are the
sort of people who do create change
right that's enough it can be surgical
and so
i don't want to go up against an enemy
that can be so surgical that most people
can be smug about pretending it doesn't
exist because it's not going to come
after them right that's a very dangerous
world and and we're there already um so
i i sincerely hope that your optimism is
well placed and i hope you can ridicule
me later for having uh seen things oh no
i'm not unconcerned about those
possibilities but what i also see is
look
uh all of us who've spoken out against
the dogma of the day on one issue or
another and we may disagree about
certain dogmas or whatever but
we've all been quote unquote punished
you won't have this experience for
example way worse than mine deeply
unpleasant i'm sure you know cathartic
in some ways but traumatic in others
you're talking about evergreen yeah i'm
talking about sovereignty yeah i'm
talking about evergreen initially right
so
that
bad bad right me you know i refuse to
sign a contract to not make offensive
jokes at a comedy show
i get kicked out of the comedy industry
blah blah blah blah again unpleasant not
really kicked out sort of just sort of
like
very different
very very different to what happened to
my grandparents
even more different to what happened to
their grandparents
in positive ways right not burn at the
stake not put in a good lag not executed
right
look i live this all the time people
come up to me specifically about the
evergreen stuff right and they say the
darkest things to me about my courage
and your hero and this and that and my
feeling is
you know i'm proud of myself but do you
realize
how safe that was compared to what
people have faced i think we've become
soft we've become really soft and you
know
look i i don't really see it go in the
direction of gas chambers but
um
what i'm con you you see it going in the
direction of digital gas chambers i get
it i know i i understand no worse than
that actually digital prisons whatever
you want to call it right no even worse
than that what i see coming is
extinction
right
extinction
and
my feeling is it is our obligation
to head that off
and the tools with which to head it off
are not at our disposal so when you say
extinction what's the path that takes us
to extinction well there are a lot of
them that could but my basic point would
be what we have is the generating
function we have tools that are scaling
up our disasters our disasters are
getting worse and worse and we haven't
had an existential one yet but we have
several things on the map that could be
that large and they're being managed by
fools
people who really don't understand what
they're doing don't understand the first
thing about complex systems right the
hubris of these people who are managing
these systems is so great that the
systems will take us out when they
mismanage them and so somehow and i know
i'm going to take a lot of crap for
using this phrase because it's the kind
it's like it's like invoking nazis right
as soon as you do you've lost the
argument it is a rush the cockpit moment
that's where we are and
i don't know how to convince you that
because frankly this is pretty
comfortable i had a lovely breakfast
this morning it all feels pretty okay
you're right comedy is coming back we're
getting our tools back they're having a
harder time throwing us off social media
all that's to the good it's not nearly
sufficient to protect us from what's
coming
i i
i don't know what you're talking about
let me give you an example
um
there is a problem where the sun
periodically throws off these bursts of
energy right now the sun is a sphere
these things are thrown off effectively
in random directions gigantic storms get
thrown off fairly regularly and mostly
they don't come anywhere near us and
every so often one does come near us and
sometimes they hit us right
we are running an incredibly large risk
that one of these is going to take out a
major section of the power grid across
an entire continent it is not
implausible that we would lose a third
of the north american power grid and
when it goes down it's not like it comes
back on a few days later the
transformers that hold this system
together that run it
it would take more than a year if you
ordered one today would take more than a
year for it to be delivered and that's
in the system that is not pressured by
the need to replace many of them
simultaneously right
now if you imagine a third of north
america going dark already you've got a
question is our
are the canadian and american
governments sufficiently competent at
this moment
to keep order under such a circumstance
well i sure don't know that they are
second thing
we have numerous nuclear reactors in
these zones
every single one of them requires a
constant input of electrical energy
or the water that is used to keep all
the spent fuel that has gone through
these reactors from catching fire
will boil away right so they all have i
think it's two weeks supply of diesel
fuel on site in order to keep them cool
probably i i think i know that most of
them have at least a month which is more
than they are legally required to have
which is great but we're talking about
doing this over the course of a year
any one of these in which the vigilance
to keep the diesel fuel flowing to those
reactors any place where that fails
turns that reactor into a nuclear
volcano well you can shut them down you
can't shut them down
you can't shut them down
and this is one of these things where
i didn't know this until fukushima
happened at which point i learned a lot
about fission power
the fact is when you run this material
through the reactor it's actually fairly
safe before it's gone through the
reactor it becomes much more dangerous
in the reactor right and then there's a
period of something like five years
where the only way to keep it from
catching fire is to keep it under water
and to keep the water circulating it
needs constant influx of cold water in
order to keep it cool right
now the reason that that stuff is still
in these reactors or on these reactor
sites is that we never made good on our
promise to find something to do with it
right when these reactors were first
built we were told look we'll figure out
where to put it well it'll be in yucca
mountain we'll find something really
stable a good place it'll go that never
happened so this stuff is all stored on
site which is really the worst place it
could be because if the reactor goes bad
it gets in the way of your ability to
manage the spent fuel that came through
it so for five years after coming out of
these reactors the stuff has to be
actively cooled
it contains
literally the worst stuff on earth right
including plutonium with a
200 000 year half-life right
really dangerous stuff and it will all
be liberated into the atmosphere if it
catches fire and it will make it
impossible to manage the rest of the
stuff that's there right all the stuff
that's been there longer than five years
could be taken out of these reactors and
it could be put in what's called dry
cask storage
dry cask storage isn't great still
highly radioactive stuff in there has a
really long half-life but it at least
doesn't require vigilance right it just
sits there inert and as long as nobody
breaks up in the container it's okay but
we're not doing that why not because it
costs money
so what i'm telling you is that
accidentally we built a doomsday device
and we distributed across north america
across europe right it's just sitting
there right and it's sitting there
waiting for a failure that could be
flung out of the sun at any minute and
at the point it gets flung out of the
sun we can calculate roughly the
likelihood that the storm will hit us we
can calculate based on how big the storm
is what the potential is for it to do
damage to our grids but there's
something we can do about it so
here's the here's the weird punch line
in that story
the remedy for this
isn't expensive right
we're talking something to solve this
problem in north america we're talking
about a sum of money that has been
estimated as something like equivalent
to a b-2 bomber
right stealth bomber
that's not a lot of money you could
tax the rich you could tax the middle
class and you could come up with that
kind of money and nobody would notice it
it's tiny right and yet we don't do it
because because the people who are
managing our system are insane they've
left this vulnerability there for no
reason it doesn't serve anybody's
interests it's just easy to ignore it
because it's kind of abstract and
technical and nobody notices it because
it's not a political winner right
so
in that world right that's when we
that's one that we can say hey we know
enough about this one to describe it
but then there's a whole series of other
things where something has been done
that we only discover after the disaster
that some process was underway that we
needed to know about ahead of time right
gain of function research how much did
you know about that before covid
i wasn't paying attention no right so
okay they're doing gain of function
research well how much more that are
they doing and on what and you know how
good is their security and how much of
it's in ukraine and what happens if
there's a war right you've got that
you've got the elizo canyon disaster in
which we're pumping
natural gas into old
oil deposits and storing it there and it
can spray a leak we've got the deepwater
horizon accident we've got the financial
collapse of 2008 right with the credit
default swaps i mean the point is people
are inventing dangerous technologies all
around us and you know what we've gotten
through all of them so far but at some
point
something that is of the appropriate
scale to take us out is going to get
unleashed and my point is
i want to know the name of every
technology that has that capacity now
and then i want really smart people who
aren't corrupt to discuss how you
properly manage it and i know that none
of that's happening
well congratulations i'm slightly less
optimistic than i was before we started
this conversation well done brett
sorry
well yeah it's you're you're we're
having a conversation completely outside
of my area of expertise so uh i don't
really have that much to to come back to
you with well look it's outside of all
of our areas of expertise i'm not a
nuclear engineer right i'm not i'm not a
i don't even know what i would need to
be a
astrophysicist to know about solar
storms at the proper level
i do know enough to evaluate this gain
of function stuff but
but really none of that is the point
right you do know enough
to say well hey that credit default swap
thing sounds like it was a bad idea
before it went bad
and then we found out about it at the
point it had gone bad and it didn't take
out the world economy but it was
of a scale that tells us that's possible
right so
so something out there
we've got a sorcerer's apprentice
problem right there's something out
there with the power to unleash things
that it cannot keep under control and we
don't
have the wisdom to address it and so
anyway i do feel see it's interesting
you make that point because credit
default swaps is something i understand
a little bit and actually what's
interesting about the 20 2008 financial
crisis is
it is the direct consequence of
the clinton
administration abandoning rules that
were set in place after the great
depression to prevent the glass-steagall
to prevent that from happening again so
it's not so much that we don't have the
companies it's more that we are
greedy enough that we think well look if
we just if we take the brakes off the
car we can go faster
right and that's how we so i understand
your concern uh but also
i suppose i'm kind of philosophical
about extinction i i fear death only as
a personal thing i fear dying if it also
if it means that my wife and child and
people i love are going to be without me
and they need me i actually i'm not that
concerned about dying if we all die
together
yeah i mean you know i've noticed that
in myself too um i don't know what it's
about it's a little odd
yeah
it's a little odd
but
i don't fear death i fear leaving people
behind who might like me or love me or
need me but i i you know i've lived a
great life already i have i have exactly
the same sense you know i'm very
comfortable with who i you know who if i
died 10 years ago i'd i'd be concerned
that i hadn't become the human being
that i could die and know that i'm proud
of that person today i'm more
comfortable in that i'm i'm like you
know this is a person who's
stuck by his principles he's done some
things that he thought were important
um he's created something who's employed
people who's made other people's lives
better who's helped his friends who's
you know all of that and so
i hear you the accelerating pace of
technological change means that we are
we're left in the hands of people that
we wouldn't otherwise choose to trust
and the catastrophe that could come from
that failure is
extinction level
sure
okay i'm okay with it brett well
all right well i hate to be this guy
because i i want to make you less okay
with it some of us are gonna survive
is that what you're going to say no
first of all i'm not entirely convinced
that that's right but it could be but i
guess the point is
i i detest the idea that some will
survive and we will leave them a greatly
diminished planet that will not recover
right they might live on it maybe it
will be possible to continue on and the
human species will do whatever is next
but it will be on a planet that we
wrecked and
i i can't be okay with that now look
there's a practical issue to all of this
prayer which is i
this everything you're saying may be
completely true um
and i'm sure there are big elements of
it there are but at the end of the day
i've always made my life about solving
the problems that i think i have a role
in and that i can solve
and the same one of them well no i
disagree with you completely um
i'll try it with two points okay
one
i agree with where you are right i've
had a great life i feel like as you i'm
in the black i have
contributed more than i have absorbed
right and so
i'm not looking to die i will avoid it
as long as possible i really don't want
to strand my family but you know if i
went to the doctor tomorrow and i got a
terminal diagnosis i would think well it
sucks that it wasn't longer but i can't
complain right
um on the other hand
we are
temporary custodians of something
something that has been
in motion for three and a half billion
years
i don't really care about it very much
you know i think the planet is full of
cool creatures and the creatures that we
were before we were human are cool and i
like all that but
the
ability to be a human being right the
ability to have the capacity to even
catch a glimpse of where we are and how
unlikely that is and what it implies
about the universe and to have some idea
of how big the universe is and to look
at really marvelous things and be
provoked and to feel love and all of
these great things right
that experience is
um there is it is the greatest
experience that could be as far as i
know
and i believe that we have an obligation
to deliver it to as many people as can
possibly experience it
now
asterisk i know that in the end none of
us get out of here alive our species
will go extinct right
the sun is going to swallow the earth i
believe before that our galaxy will
collide with andromeda which ain't going
to be pretty right even if we were to
escape these galaxies ultimately you
know the universe either goes cold or
you know hot or whatever the end might
be
but the point is in the end
philosophically speaking
even whatever we might accomplish as a
species and whatever we might escape
it'll get us in the end
that said
that right there
could be an argument for not taking my
next breath
but i'm not listening right i'm taking
my next breath i'm going to enjoy the
hell out of this i'm going to do as much
good as i can and i'm going to do
everything in my power to deliver this
opportunity
to people in the future because that's
what i'm supposed to be doing right
that's what we are and we don't quite
get it because
evolution built us to perceive and to
contemplate only those things in which
there would be value in us perceiving
and contemplating which for our
ancestors wasn't very far in the future
they didn't they didn't have any power
over the future
we have ultimate power over the future
so we have to correct our
thinking and we have to start seeing our
distant descendants as important which
isn't easy because they are completely
anonymous and mysterious to us but i
still feel i have an obligation to them
and if we blink out tomorrow
i'm not going to feel shortchanged but
i'm going to feel a
deep sense of shame
that we failed them
i hear you
what i'm saying though is that
i it's not so much that i i'm not
unaware of the existence of our future
descendants it's more that i can only
solve the problems that i'm able to
solve
right
based on my skills and and and
the the limited talents that i have
right and the influence that i can exert
in the world and by the way my biggest
concern is that always all of us you and
me included are acting in ways whose
consequences we can't predict and so
if we can
strive to address a particular problem
what what is the other problem that look
covet is a very good example of this
right a real disease comes along
uh and
whichever way it came along and it needs
addressing and so we as a society go
well we've got to address this problem
and we start doing things some of which
personally i agree with some of it's
personally i disagree with and i think
in many cases the solution may have been
worse than the problem that we were
trying to solve on some issues right
so
in that desire to make the world a
better place i'm wary of people who who
are
so confident in their own ability to
solve these problems consequence-free
that they
sort of push us down that line i i'm
i'm and i'm wary of my own
kind of inability to to play a positive
role in solving this so there's some
things that i can do and i'm doing them
beyond that i i'm not able to solve the
problems you're describing uh in any
meaningful way
well i mean i agree with your
formulation the problem is people whose
hubris causes them to think they can
solve problems and to uh be
unimaginative about the unintended
consequences i'm totally on board with
that i mean this is this is the flaw of
progressivism right you don't spot the
unintended consequences you you do the
thing that you think needs to be done
and then do make things worse but what
i'm talking about is actually
shutting down a kind of cryptic
progressivism right gain of function
research do you know why we're doing all
this gain of function research
well allegedly to stop the next pandemic
right but here's the thing we've got an
academic system
in which you rise based on your ability
to tell a really compelling narrative
about why your work is so damn vital
right these people told us a really good
story about how human beings are in more
contact with nature because as we expand
we're pushing it back well that's
actually [ __ ] we are expanding and
pushing it back but we're in less
contact with nature never mind they also
told us that they were all of these
viruses in nature that were ready to
leap out and get us well it's true that
they're there but they didn't really get
the evolutionary part right they didn't
explain to us how difficult it was for a
virus to make that jump and they didn't
explain to us that the thing that they
were going to have to do in order to do
that work was solve that problem for the
viruses
that they were going to take the viruses
into the lab and solve a very difficult
evolutionary problem in order to study
what would happen if some virus solved a
very difficult evolutionary problem that
was insane
right they created this this is an
entirely man-made disaster
it was born of this kind of runaway
progressivism exactly of the sort you're
talking about hey we'll solve the
problem of the next pandemic
yes but the chances that you will cause
the next pandemic are a thousand times
greater than you will get ahead of the
next pandemic i mean look
they studied this exact clade of viruses
did they do us any good at all in
controlling it
as far as i can tell even if their story
which i consider to be obvious [ __ ]
at this point even if their story that
this came either from nature or the wet
market
was true
they didn't know enough to do anything
useful to control the pandemic right
they've they've shown us how much
[ __ ] was in their grant proposals
and
so what i'm saying is look
we do know enough to control these
things because the primary thing we have
to do to control them is stop making
these stupid errors we have to shut down
that naive desire to do new cool things
and this is where your progressive
nature comes out of you brett because
you think that's possible i do it's not
well then we're done we are done this is
why i'm philosophical about it have you
read a conflict of visions by thomas sol
i haven't it's very good he talks about
he basically says that there are two
visions of the world one of which he
describes is the constrained vision and
the other is the unconstrained vision
and and
the constrained vision is which says
human beings are fallible they're flawed
they're not perfect uh war is inevitable
disease is inevitable stupidity is
inevitable all these things will happen
and we've got to prepare for that and
mitigate those things as best we can the
unconstrained version is progressivism
which says
human beings are ultimately perfectable
we can be made to to not have these
flaws we can be made not to have these
areas you're never going to stop people
from [ __ ] with the world man it's not
gonna happen that's not what i'm saying
you're not and you're never gonna get
them away from the levels of power
you're never gonna get them to not
invent powerful things that could
destroy us
that's what we do well here's the thing
first of all until i know you know
even if i believed 98 that what you just
said was true as long as there's a two
percent that we might be able to rein in
this instinct i am morally obligated to
pursue it but we can't no you're saying
that with a level of certainty that
isn't justified why not has there ever
been a period in human history where we
haven't done this let me explain
something
human
human culture and human societies as a
special version of human culture
is an evolved
property okay it is organism-like not in
every way but in some ways
if you understand how a hummingbird
works
right a hummingbird
is
utterly imperfect in every regard
there's not a single system in the thing
that's perfect right but it functions as
if perfect okay it functions
beyond
what one can conceive of the level of
functionality is beyond plausible right
now how does it work
well mostly we don't know but everything
we do know about it involves
feedbacks
feedbacks that detect when some
parameter is moving in a direction
that's going to make the thing fall out
of the sky and it moves it back every
single thing is modulated right
now
that's not an easy trick to accomplish
we don't have it built into civilization
yet and it
hasn't needed to be there because the
technologies we were playing with you
might take out your population but you
weren't going to take out the species
right
now we're all so
interlinked there are so many of us we
are burning the resources of the planet
at such a rate that actually there's a
clock ticking and my point is it is not
inconceivable that you could build and
you know i've been pretty specific about
this i'm not saying
we know how to build that system we
definitely do not know how to build that
system but what we do know is enough
to prototype it
right to say here's what the system must
not do and here's what it must
accomplish and here are the parameters
that ought to be
that ought to be the bounds of these
things and we know how to we know how to
prototype it and you know what
your first prototype is pretty damn
crude but if it proves you can do it
then you know what to do next the
purpose of a prototype is to teach you
what you don't know and so my point is
not hey we got to regulate this thing
let's do it i don't know how to do it
nobody else does either i assure you but
what we need to do is get some
uncorrupted people uncorrected this is
why you lose me what
the uncorrupted people
right
corruption is is a function of existence
and it and of hierarchy
right you know my point is you're not
going to get a system where people have
power where some people aren't corrupt
it's impossible i'm not saying no people
will be corrupt what we need is a system
that your corruption costs you more than
it benefits you that it moves you away
from power rather than towards it we
have the exact opposite but that is in
direct contradiction to the interests of
corrupt people who always will have the
power in the system that of the kind
that we have i think you're making my
point no no i think i'm making my point
well but then you're never gonna get
away from that well you say never gonna
get away from that but i think that
assumes this system right
look uh like i said this is your
progressive coming out
well but but okay fair that's a that's a
fair it's a fair challenge but
understand something i call myself a
reluctant radical
okay
and what that means is i believe only
radical change will save us and radical
change is inherently so dangerous it
should terrify you so i am not a
progressive by virtue of the fact that
i'm enthusiastic
you know that right of course yeah of
course but no look i think this is
important because i think you do
disagree with me and i think i am trying
to make a point that frankly
you know i don't love saying this
because i i hear uh
um
i hear a mechanism
at work that actually liberates a friend
of mine from a kind of obligation that
frankly probably we can't meet and is
really unpleasant so i don't necessarily
want to inflict it on you but i do think
that you know in terms of being
philosophically consistent
we aren't cooked yet and you know what
you may think well i don't know
anything about nuclear power gain
function research blah blah blah
therefore i'm not really in a position
to do anything anyway so i'm going to go
back to not worrying about it but the
fact is actually
you are in exactly the business
where you probably have as much say as
anyone else
i don't think that's true but here's the
thing you're
in
the business of persuading people of
things that they can't see
no no i i
see this is i think one of the big
problems that we're gonna and this is
one of the
problems we've created by creating the
sort of society and culture that we have
now is people like me
are in a position now where they're
supposed to influence things and
you know have these conversations about
important issues like covet or this or
that i actually think
i
think it was a mistake to get involved
in the conversations around these issues
as much as i have done
and going forward
my aim is to avoid that as much as i can
because
i'm not qualified to make these calls or
to influence people's on these issues
and
the longer i go the more i realize the
thing we've just been talking about
which is unintended consequence of
things uh so i was i think quite careful
to
talk about my issues with our response
to covid
from a position of saying look i don't
know what the medical side of this is i
don't know if ivamectin works i don't
know how good or safe or whatever the
vaccine is all i know is i'm
uncomfortable with forcing people to do
things they don't want to do in a free
society like the ones that we have and
that is is and remains my position i
think uh
my view was always look
is as i understand it and i don't
understand it but as i understand it the
vaccine is relatively safe and the
trade-offs are worth it for people who
are in a certain age category who are in
a certain health category etc and if i
was not you should but if i was in your
position
i would take it right that was always my
view and it remains my view by the way
it remains my view that
based on what i have seen masks are
ineffective at stopping the transmission
of covet 19 right
so enforcing a vaccine and mask wearing
and all of this stuff on people is wrong
and i disagree with it on a civil
society freedom of
conscience basis but for people like me
to be involved in the conversations
around the medical stuff i actually
think is a mistake and not one i'm gonna
repeat sure but uh let me ask you this
why do you think the vaccines are on
balance safe enough and effective enough
uh because that's what i've been told by
whom by the powers that be whatever
that's probably better than that right
you wouldn't have listened to the powers
that be necessarily but you might have
listened to a wide range of people who
were better and i've listened to people
who are very critical of them and people
who are very supportive of them and i've
made up my mind based on what i've seen
from those different sources but suppose
suppose somebody could take you to a
place where you could just simply stand
and look at how that consensus came to
be and that the nature of that consensus
was that it was entirely coerced and
supposed that you from what you do
understand
could look and say well
had this been allowed to unfold
naturally had doctors been allowed to
voice their concerns there would be no
consensus whatsoever and in fact we
would know these things but we don't
know them because the people who said
them have been booted off of our
social networks they've been punished
they've been stigmatized their wikipedia
pages have been vandalized right suppose
you knew that the consensus itself was
the product of an intense campaign to
create an impression that is false
if you could take me to that room and i
could observe it with my own eyes sure
but that's never going to happen well i
don't know that it is or it isn't but
it's not going to happen
well because you're not going to go no
because there is no such room to which i
can be transported that room is in the
past if it even exists oh i don't think
it is um
the fact is
there are places that you could stand i
don't know that it would nail it down
100 for you but there are places that a
guy with your intellect and your skill
set
would look at that consensus and say
now i don't know what to think because
if this was a natural consensus none of
this coercion would have been necessary
right
i mean for example
i'm not asking you to make a conclusion
about ivermectin but
the fact
that intense pressure was put on
pharmacists not to fill prescriptions
for ivermectin tells you
that whatever those powers were were
ineffective at convincing doctors not to
prescribe it
right they convinced the public this
drug doesn't work
and then they went after your pharmacist
because your doctor couldn't be
convinced that should tell you something
right that's a very interesting fact
and it's not the only one of its kind
right i mean
again we're we're talking about things
in which i have no expertise but
i am unpersuaded uh that that is the
equivalent of taking me to a room in
which i observe
large-scale coordinated coercion that is
one
element of something that happened there
could be plenty of alternative
explanations why happen for example
terrible public policy
reaction to a
panic
right right whatever those things that
look governments do stupid [ __ ] all the
time right and they do it uh not because
always because there's a conspiracy or
because there's something going wrong
but because governments are flawed and
they make mistakes right and this has
happened time and time again and they've
made mistakes that have killed people
and they've lied about stuff that has
killed people but it's not necessarily
evidence of a grand scale
coercive
thing
i'm unpersuaded of that and also i've
listened to a lot of people who who are
very critical i've interviewed as you
know plenty of people who are critical
of everything that's been happening
i'm unpersuaded by some of those people
i'm very unpersuaded by some of those
people i find them to be in my opinion
based on what i see quite untrustworthy
i see a lot of holes in their arguments
um
and
the the main thing for me is i'm not
seeing
uh evidence with my own eyes from people
who i know large numbers of people who
are vaccinated have had any issue with
it so again
i'm balancing all this up as a complete
non-expert
and on balance i've arrived at that
position that i described to you earlier
and
my point to you is
remember how we started this portion of
the conversation i'm not qualified to be
opining on that in public well either
way no no either way you are qualified
to notice a coerced consensus and infer
that something isn't right
um i am
aware that there's coercion happening i
am unpersuaded that that coercion is
anything other than a government doing a
bad job at trying to get people not to
be ill
well first of all it's not a bad job
right again i'm going to take you back
to ivermectin and i'm not asking you to
pass judgment on this molecule but what
i'm saying is
either
this drug
is
was the key to preventing many of the
people who died from covid from dying of
code or it's not
right so to the extent that the
government is doing a bad job people die
as a result in large numbers oh sure but
that that's not what i mean what i mean
is the communication around it so let's
take the position the ivormectin doesn't
work right
it therefore would make sense
for a government that's imperfect that
is dealing with a pandemic that is
firefighting stuff that's got a lot of
stuff going on to react authority in in
a place where they are allowed to act in
an authoritarian way right to go down
that path and to make a decision like
that that looks one way but actually
it's an expression of them trying badly
to deal with a problem and the pr stuff
around it for example in this country we
had vaccine mandates uh being considered
for uh people who work in the nhs right
do i think that is because there's some
plot to to whatever i don't i don't even
know what what the allegation is i
personally don't i think the government
is like a big oil tanker and their thing
was we got a self-covered we've got a
vaccine we've got to say
and they went down this path and it took
people like us to stand up and go go
hold on you can't coerce people to take
this and they're relented and by the way
covert itself had got to a point where
it was less dangerous so they felt less
pressure and that's how that got
eradicated i think a lot of a lot of the
evil that happens in the world is people
trying to do good as they understand it
oh no doubt no doubt um
but
my experience with the iron acting which
strangely i find to be the stickiest
wicket right lab leak i believe that we
effectively made the case successfully
that the overwhelming preponderance of
evidence pointed to the lab and not to
naturally not persuaded by that argument
right and i think most people are so i
wasn't expecting us to win that argument
but i believe that we did
the vaccine argument right we can
reasonable people can disagree over the
net impact of those vaccines but the
idea that they are simply safe and
effective people are aware that that
cannot be the case the fact that they
are being told that they need booster
after booster after booster challenges
the idea that they were highly effective
right these were weak narrow vaccines
the fact that they haven't been updated
for the change in variance is
conspicuous
and the fact is
there are a large number of adverse
events now
a large number of adverse events is not
an argument against using a vaccine
there has to be some sort of net
analysis so reasonable people can
disagree over that but nonetheless
people are awake to the fact that they
were told an overly simple story about
vaccines which didn't stand up yeah and
people are aware of the fact that this
virus appears to have been modified in a
lab and when they finally understand
what that means that will be a very
important fact people still believe
well the early treatment thing that was
that was a false start it the stuff
doesn't work hydromectin doesn't work
but
there is a room that i could take you to
where i could show you that all of the
pieces of evidence that cause people to
believe that have a strange fact when
you lift up the rock right and i would
encourage you to look there's a very
nice
short piece of video which i will link
in the description to this one
[Music]
um in which have you seen there's a
there's two videos there's one raw piece
of video in which tess laurie confronts
andrew hill
uh on a zoom call have you seen that no
okay do you know who andrew hill is you
probably don't you know who tess laurie
is no okay tess laurie is a
former
consultant to the who a highly placed
she's a medical doctor and an analyst
and she has
done with the bird group the
meta-analysis that says ivermectin is a
highly effective treatment
for kova treatment and prophylactic
there is another meta-analysis done by
andrew hill which says actually it's not
effective okay
so the question is which of these
meta-analyses is correct
now
the fact is andrew hill
believed that ivermectin was a highly
effective prophylactic and treatment
and in early versions of his paper he
said so
he then reversed that conclusion and on
videotape he acknowledges to test laurie
that the reason he did that is he was
pressured by people who are not named as
authors of his paper right unitaid
now
it is conspicuous that the world is
persuaded that the evidence suggests
maybe it doesn't work and at best it's
conflicted and then you look at the part
that says it doesn't work and you pick
up the rock and you find the admission
that there was external pressure to
reverse a conclusion that the author
themself believed it to be effective and
then changed their conclusion in print
right
it's not the only time we've seen that
you've heard of the recent together
trial you've heard of this trial they
will say it's the largest randomized
controlled trial done to date on
ivermectin and it says iremectin doesn't
work at all
well that's not what it says that's what
the paper implies but it is not what the
data inside the paper implies and it is
also inconsistent with what the lead
author on the paper has said in email
emails you can read yourself where he
says i think the only reason that this
showed up as not effective was that we
didn't bring enough patients into the
trial had we brought more patients into
the trial it would have shown up as
highly effective the author of the paper
says that himself now we can go we could
go for hours on all of the flaws in this
trial but nonetheless if every time you
go to the evidence that might have
persuaded a government bureaucrat that
the stuff didn't work and therefore
gotten them to get in the way and you
know strong arm your pharmacist right if
all of the things on which such a
decision might have been predicated all
have this weird underbelly right where
somebody is exerting pressure where the
data doesn't match the conclusion of the
paper where the conclusion of the paper
is announced seven months before we're
allowed to see the method section right
when that's happening again and again
it's like it's like your bank has made
50 errors right if those errors were
random if half the time they went in
your favor you might say this is a
[ __ ] up bank right if they all go in
the bank's favor it's not a [ __ ] up
bank right it's a criminal bank
this is why we come back to to the point
that i met earlier which is i'm not
qualified to have this conversation with
you because a person who's qualified to
have this conversation with you knows
what the other things that have happened
along the way are he they know about
however meccan has been used in india
and they know about however mechanisms
been used in south america and they can
give you the data and the trials and
they can say well this will happen here
this will happen here all i'm qualified
to do is sit here and nod along as you
list things about which you know and i
don't no no look i'm not telling you
that you're qualified in this
conversation to have an opinion for one
thing you don't know that i've
represented these things accurately
that's my point right but and it's not
that i don't trust you i just know that
you have a particular view of it of
course but my point is there's a room
you could stand in or we could say look
what is the list of evidence that has
caused people to imagine that this is
not a useful direction and to go in
another direction and we could say let
us look at each one in turn i'm not
saying that you're ever going to be
qualified to talk about ivermectin its
mechanism of action or even make a
judgment about its net effect but you
are qualified to say something isn't
right here the informational environment
is not what would be necessary i've said
that many times right that doesn't prove
that ivamectin works to me right
what i would say is i absolutely my
criticism of of the response to covet
has been that we've been given
inaccurate oversimplified messaging uh
coercion has been lent on
far more than explanation right um and i
think those are all big problems in a
free society against which i've
protested and stood up and stood in
parliament and talked to people who were
there because i genuinely think that was
wrong and bad and set a terrible
precedent
none of those things convinced me or
unconvinced me or whatever the opposite
of convinced me about the medical side
of things because like i said i don't
understand it and i actually think it's
time
that you know we were talking we started
this conversation about how uh people in
my position have a role to to address
some of these big problems
i actually don't think that's true and
and i think um in in many ways i liked
when joe rogan came out and he said look
i'm gonna stop talking to politicians
because i don't want to be a player in
this field
and when it comes to this stuff that
we're talking about i don't want to be a
player in that so if the government is
coming and taking your rights away and
saying if you don't take the vaccine
we're going to fire you from the job i'm
going to stand up and say that's wrong
well right if the government is forcing
you to wear a nappy on your face it
doesn't work right
yeah you're going to stay i'm going to
stand up and say that's wrong if the
government is forcing you to live in a
quarantined facility when you have a
disease that is akin to flu i'm gonna
stand up and say that's wrong but all of
this other stuff it becomes a little bit
above my pay grade is my point and
that's why
i think uh you know you talked earlier
about sort of like well this is a
problem you you don't feel capable
solving so you solve the ones that you
can actually i do think that's a recipe
for for a sane person in my opinion
there are many many things i could worry
about in the world on which i have
absolutely no impact
uh and on which my inter interference
will probably make things worse rather
than better and rather than focusing my
energies on that my energy is limited
i'm going to focus on fighting for the
things that i do understand that i do
think are important and that i can make
a difference on and that's what i've
been doing so
this is not me rejecting what you're
saying this is not me taking a position
either way or neither mectin or or
vaccines or anything like that all i'm
saying is i think the time for people
like me interfering in things like
public health policy is at an end
well and it should be at an end maybe
and that's what i'm saying
i respect that and i also hear
um a lot of us got chewed up in this
battle i don't think i had any choice
about it right i'm not saying anything
about what you i know but i'm just
saying i hear
you know
this was the worst informational
environment i've ever seen on any topic
probably by an order of magnitude agreed
okay this was crazy and
the level of lunacy look
we're going to get off this topic in a
second because i don't want to keep
pushing you right i respect you and i
understand what you're saying and there
is a logic to it and if i didn't think
that basically this system
uh this failure all things coveted
revealed the
level of degradation the level of
corruption of our system if i didn't
think that i wouldn't be so focused on
it but i do think that this reveals the
depth of the problem it reveals the fact
that you know
the pilot died and
we don't know it because the autopilot
is still on right that that level of
problem is where we are and this this
story tells it right
but
even just the simple fact
that anthony fauci appears to be
vital in the chain that circumvented the
us ban on gain of function research and
offshored it to wuhan right he's central
to that and he's central to the vaccine
campaign right when somebody has screwed
up so badly as to have been
an important player in the causing of
the catastrophe why he's in any position
to mandate anything about what remedy i
use for myself and my family for a virus
that in some sense he unleashed on the
world how the hell that makes any sense
i don't know my feeling is look maybe
ivermectin doesn't work maybe the
vaccines are better than i think but i'm
entitled to make that choice because
they have demonstrated they're
incompetent well
that that is where you and i come into
complete agreement my issue with all of
this is personal liberty right
you have the right to take a drug that's
going to kill you if that's what you
decide to do because you think it solves
this or that problem and i'm not saying
by the way iphone x is going to kill you
or it doesn't solve i'm just saying you
have a right as an individual free
citizen to make your own decision about
your health the government can give you
advice the government can give you
information the government can give you
even if it wants some kind of
bonus incentive if it wants to give you
a free hamburger because you've got a
vaccine not that that makes much sense
to me but if that's what it wants to do
that's fine by me but when the
government starts saying you're going to
lose your job when the government starts
saying we're gonna we're gonna punish
you when the government starts saying
we're gonna put you in some kind of
facility when the government starts
taking stuff away like your freedoms
sure i'm with you i'm with you you
should be able to take over mecdon if
you want you should be able to take or
not take the vaccine if you want and
that that to me you know the you know we
talked earlier about comparison to nazis
but in 1945 some pretty smart people
came together and went we shouldn't
force people to take medical
interventions they don't want to do
completely [ __ ] good reasons oh and
this is um this is exactly where we are
we are now
in the process of um
reversing nuremberg
and to me that's a big problem huge and
i'm right with you on that what i'm
saying to you however is when it comes
to this other stuff
yes the experts have discredited
themselves
that does not make me an expert true and
that's the problem i have with with all
of this conversation which is
fascinating to me and it's interesting
talking to you about it all i'm saying
to you is i'm not going to continue to
be a player in this in this game in any
way because it's not an area in which i
understand enough
well and reading stuff online and
watching experts excellents from videos
or whatever isn't going to make me an
expert
right but you do understand nuremberg
and so
here's why that's where i stand with you
you
you have made a very clear statement
about nuremberg about personal liberty
and i just want to add one thing to this
and explain
a why i'm interested in the couple of
steps over here where
you're correct you probably don't have
the background to do the analysis and
maybe i do but um
the problem is what i saw with the
violations of nuremberg was that there
were two
right or at least there's two levels one
there is the fact that there was no
informed consent right no informed
consent that is not acceptable right we
hung people at nuremberg over this okay
now
the second thing though
is that
the mandates and the fact that people
would not accept them caused people to
be purged from
role after role in society our military
was purged of people who wouldn't accept
the vaccines
government was purged universities were
purged
and
that is alarming to me almost beyond
anything else i've seen because what it
does is it means that the entire machine
is now staffed with people who have been
selected for their tendency not to
notice a problem with these mandates
right that means when immoral orders are
handed down whatever they might be the
chances that somebody stands up and says
not on my watch has gone way down all of
a sudden right so i believe we are being
set up for a tragedy of history no i
don't expect it to go step no i don't
expect it to involve gas chambers but i
do expect it to be catastrophic and the
chances that we headed off
are lower because the thing went across
civilization and used this mechanism to
take those who had a tendency to stand
up and say no and get rid of them all at
once okay that is that is to me
very frightening so
i guess what i'm saying is look
i don't like that the story that gets us
to that conversation involves technical
details mechanisms of action physiology
epidemiology all of that stuff but
nonetheless it's one step over right the
fact that i'm not allowed to choose to
take ironmectin and i am being required
to take this vaccine in order to do all
sorts of normal things right that is
the thing that sits right adjacent to
the fact that hey
when did we forget nuremberg right why
is nuremberg not on everybody's lips at
this moment right so i guess i guess
what i'm saying is
yeah you could you can draw a line you
can say i'm not going to talk about
anything physiological or
epidemiological but it doesn't get you
out of this discussion because
i'm not trying to get out of the
discussion i'm trying to keep my
involvement to areas in which i'm able
to to have a
sensible conversation based on facts and
information that i have so i'm
whatever the the what sits underneath
that conversation about freedom and
personal liberty is not for me to
comment on all i'm saying is
if brett weinstein thinks however making
works it doesn't know this person or
whatever i don't really care about that
what i care about is is the government
forcing you to do things that you should
be free to make your own choice about
well you should also care about um
capture in this case
pharma capture which i think is the most
elaborate capture that exists and you
should care about the complete collapse
of uh academia and scientific research
because you know
in order for me to make a decent
decision with respect to whether to take
this or that treatment informed consent
is entirely predicated on my ability to
understand what is even under discussion
and i don't understand what is even
under discussion because the system that
is supposed to tell me is thoroughly
corrupted which incidentally
isn't the least bit new
yeah right we knew this before covid
and in fact every rational person you
know above a certain level of education
was pretty well aware that something was
wrong with pharma's relationship with
its regulators and you know that that
capture
meant that you were likely to have
things recommended to you that might not
be in your medical interest look one of
the things i've said from very early on
in my sort of public life in any way is
i don't understand why we don't
incentivize whistleblowing
yes you do well sure
yes i do but you know what i mean yes um
i imagine that is a very popular public
policy with the general public
and i don't understand why people who
come forward and expose genuine
corruption first of all aren't given
lifetime immunity from all sorts of
negative consequences and number two are
not financially incentivized to come out
and blow the whistle
that to me seems like a very simple and
elegant solution to many of the problems
that we face as a society and i'd quite
like to see that and this is why i come
back to my point is i think on issues of
culture and politics i have something to
say that's of value
and that's what i'm going to focus on
and i leave it up to people who are more
scientifically uh trained to talk about
that side of it uh that's why we're
having this what my people my people
might perceive as a disagreement it's
just me
being unwilling to engage in things on
which i'm not qualified to comment oh
okay well look i mean let me just make
this clear what i think you are
qualified to comment on and you know
look you and i are going to partner okay
you're going to talk about societal
stuff and to the extent that there's
biology or something
i'll take over but i would like to be
able to point out to you hey the conduct
of research that's society that's not
biology right and so if i can show you
hey there is a pervasive pattern
everywhere that the supposed evidence
says x
you pick up the rock and the same thing
is underneath it then the point is look
you can interpret that no i can't
because i have to be confident that
there are not counter factuals to what
you're saying and while i like and trust
you there are other people that i like
and trust that believe there are
counterfacts fair enough and that's the
point of which i have to be an expert to
make a judgment and i'm not an expert
actually no and what i would hope in
that case is that you would actually
hear both sides which i have case
well you probably haven't if you're not
aware of the andrew hill fiasco right
the man's caught red-handed now my point
to you would be
the video
is incredibly remarkable
andrew hill
is not
what he did is
standard academic corruption now you
probably wouldn't know right but i think
the point is our system is actually
because of the way it depends on people
selling their own work selling the
importance of it
to granting agencies to employers right
because that's the nature of the thing
it trains scientists to be salesmen it's
a disaster right because once you're in
that mindset you can't do science
science requires you to try to prove
your own ideas wrong right it's a weird
skill
so anyway the point is there is a
pervasive problem you can see it i would
love for you to hear the full
explanation from both sides and then i
think you would be able to come to a
conclusion one that you're fully
qualified to come to not on the
underlying issue but on
what is taking place in science and what
is the quality of this see this is why i
disagree with you again because and this
is a fundamental problem of our time
which i think is why we're focusing as
much as we are
most people who are in my position
we make all of our decisions about
things like this that we don't
understand based on the
how much we trust the people who are
arguing for the different sides of it
we like to pretend that people sit down
and analyze all the evidence from both
sides that's not what happens of course
right so
essentially i'm making a decision based
on whether i trust brett more than i
trust yuri or whether i trust yuri more
than i trust brett uh and how persuasive
they are delivering their argument and
how much i personally like them and
whatever
and and that's the way that decision is
going to get made either way well first
of all you you say that
as if it's shameful i would just point
out that actually you know this is this
is the cartesian problem right descartes
got spooked when he realized that almost
everything he knew was predicated on
authority and not on his own experience
exactly um and that's where we are stuck
all of us right there's too much to know
and we you know how many of us have run
the experiments with that would validate
even the most basic things we think we
know right so we're stuck there um but
that means that to the extent that
there's a corruption problem in the
authority structure
it ought to be a major concern and
and that is that is what i'm getting at
to the extent that you see hey
there's a problem in
in the conduit that gets us here that's
going to do this again on the next topic
right and we're going to keep being i
don't know locked down injected
forced to make decisions about drugs we
don't know anything about right who
knows we can't afford this and so you
know
we step back to the beginning of the
conversation
this is my point is that actually we
don't have a choice but to try to get
civilization moved over to something
that doesn't do this to us routinely
right
and
it is not a simple job um but uh i do
think
i think your role is surprisingly
important because the number of people
who
remember how to think clearly right who
are able to do that job well and to
model it frankly for other people who
are trying to understand what to think
is pretty small right well one of the
things i'm keen to model going forward
is not getting involved in conversations
about things i don't understand i think
way too many of us
way too many of us have concluded
that the fact that we have over a
hundred thousand twitter followers means
that we know something or means that
we're experts i see this the biggest
shock to me has been the war in ukraine
ukraine of course
uh because i suddenly see a lot of
people with whom i've naturally i'm
naturally aligned temperamentally
commenting on things they have no idea
about with a level of confidence that is
grotesque
and
that's an eye opener for me and i know
that i've behaved in that way in the
past as well
all right let me ask you a question have
you noticed me do that no no i haven't
done it i'm not accusing you of it i
know that i am what i was saying is i'm
accusing myself of it well
no i look first of all this is a this is
a difficult
this is a difficult job to navigate
right it's very confusing it's it's a
hall of mirrors right i've been very
careful about ukraine i have instincts
about it but i know that i don't know
right and so a i would just point out
that i am sensitive to the idea that yes
everybody seems to think that they have
to formulate an opinion they have to do
so quickly they have to you know
i don't know they're defending their
brand or whatever it is that they're
doing um
i don't think it's that by the way if i
can interject quickly i think we've got
a position that troubles me tremendously
which is we now formulate our opinions
about what's true
based on who else has the opposite
opinion so if team blue
has an opinion then team red has to have
the exact and opposite opinion and given
that i hate team blue as much as i hate
team red
and i think they're both moronic and
stupid and i think the whole tribal team
thing is the problem yeah is the problem
is the problem i am not going to engage
in any of this tribal [ __ ] anymore in
any way because i'm just i'm really
really really not interested in
perpetuating that dynamic having said
that i come back to the thomas soul
point which is that's how human beings
are we are tribal
we are trying well wait a second wait a
second the problem is it's a fractal
okay
we are tribal right we might be tribal
in a particular you know a literal room
of a small number of people we might
divide into two factions right
that room of people you know
has an interest in the larger structure
that allows there to be a room surviving
and they might be united by that thing
and so my point is we are tribal we are
also trapped together on the same planet
and there ought to be things about which
we are not tribal oh i agree the
tribalism is bizarre so the experience
you had
where you saw all sorts of people who um
you were aligned with over issues of
wokism and the hazards
therein who suddenly were mouthing off
about ukraine in ways that you knew
weren't right right i saw that exact
thing with copen right and so
it was fascinating in fact that all
sorts of people who
uh had been extremely reasonable
on
locism
uh
were
well heather and i began to call it
medically woke that they came to the
consensus position and i would just say
look i know you don't want to be talking
about kobe let's skip it but the point
is covid revealed something
the
whatever the thing is on the other side
conspiracy emergent property some
mixture
of those two things
it drives us to formulate positions
instantaneously and in part this makes
us vulnerable to manipulation right to
the extent that the idea was oh the good
people have ukrainian flags in their
twitter bio it's how you spot them right
the fact that that happened inside of
was it ours right the spreading of this
thing is very subtle right it's a
ukrainian flag they've been attacked i
mean who's for people being attacked
right but on the other hand the point
was it was a jersey
right and that's too much of this is
about jersey and not the actual content
and
a i would expect and i would hope what
you're really saying is that people
should have a lot more disagreement
there should be a lot more a la carte
you know i'm with you on this i disagree
with you on that and i don't hate you
over our disagreements right that's the
natural honorable adult way to do it
but that's not the way it is the way
every topic comes down to
the people on the other side of the bad
ones yeah well this is as you say an
emerging property of social media and
the environment that we operate in which
is one of the reasons why i'm actually
again
withdrawing from having these
conversations on social media because i
don't actually think it's productive and
you know how you talk about the
ukrainian flag in bio
i don't
it was not my experience at least
initially that
that that so for example people probably
think i'm quite pro ukraine i don't i
never put flags in my bio just because i
don't put flags in my bio it's not what
i do right i just tell you what i think
about this issue i'm not gonna i'm not i
don't want an identity to come with my
opinions i just want to be able to think
for myself
but the fact that people experience
people putting flags for ukraine in
their bio as a team signaling thing
is a product of a system in which
everyone thinks there's teams for me i
see a lot of people with ukraine flags
in the bio i just think some of them
support ukraine i don't think they're on
team team blue or team red or team this
or team that and i think that's the
problem of social media is everyone is
incentivized to think of everything as a
team the people who take on an identity
are incentivized to think of themselves
as team that identity and the people who
oppose it which is the dynamic you're
now seeing more and more now have an
identity of opposing this team that
they've invented partly in their head
well
even worse than that though is that once
it becomes a team question rather than
an analysis question
we have this
very
troubling propensity
to then impose on the underlying logic
uh a clarity that is not justified in
other words if somebody
whose ultimate point is opposed to the
one that i subscribe to says something
it is false
now that's not a logical statement right
my point is look i know how analytical
arguments go the fact is some of you you
may be arguing with me and i may be
right but some of your points are
accurate and have to be incorporated in
my model right that's the once you get
into tribal conflict that goes out of
the window it goes out the window and so
i you know i'm
noticing that even the simple fact of
the ukrainian flag in bio
preceding your reading of the tweet in
general just you know it's first and so
the point is
how do i feel about this tweet before
i've read the first word of it right
that's a bad habit right it's a very bad
habit and it gets us into
you know a place where
i don't know the argument isn't even an
argument it's just it's it's warfare
yeah it's it's usa usa it's that kind of
you know jingoistic or it's equivalent
agreed and so you know one of in my
opinion is one of the biggest problems
for us to solve a society and that's one
i don't feel i'm qualified to solve but
certainly i'm qualified to pitch in on
right
because it's something that i observe
quite a bit i talk to people who who
have certain views of it that i think
are interesting and that's what i'm
gonna focus on because we do need
you know this
all that social media has done is it's
brought out the instincts that are
within us but made them way more
powerful
way more powerful
and so that tribalism we're seeing it's
inherent in human beings but we've now
got a really really powerful tool it's
like the nuclear weapon of communication
um
you say i'm gonna quibble
you say all that it's done
no you're correct no not all that it's
done it's not even all that it's done it
has done what you're saying it has also
armed
those with resources who wish to shape
our discussions and
let's be honest we have no idea how
effective they have been right
but
to the extent
that somebody wishes to shape your view
on a topic
they have some power tools it's almost
like they have the ability to whisper in
your ear because they can appear to be
an organic belief system arriving in
your replies right
and that is potent and you know
i struggle with the following problem
i'm not good at keeping track of stuff
right i will read a paper it's a very
good paper and i won't be able to find
it again
and there's a whole list of things that
we have known at one point that i know
are important
that i
i know we are losing track of the fact
that they ever even happened so you know
just prior to edward snowden for example
there was a
he was i believe he's a graduate student
he may have been a postdoc at mit who
gave a talk at a tech conference in
which he proved that i believe they were
hp printers
that could be hijacked these were
networked printers they could be
hijacked by printing an infected
document and what the document would do
is it would cause the printer network
architecture to take on a loophole
that would allow anyone to use that if
they knew it was there to use that as a
portal to get into the network so if you
had one of these on your network
anywhere and you printed a bad document
then your network was compromised there
was nothing you could do about it what's
more you couldn't even update the
firmware to get rid of it right that
printer had to go i don't know how many
people even know that right that's an
important fact that's a huge
vulnerability
but it just vanished right
so
there are all of these things now i also
remember
that the navy was invested in software
that allowed it to manage large numbers
of sock puppet accounts
right this was in the early days of
twitter and facebook
the navy
sock puppet accounts
social media
huh that's awfully interesting what
effect is that having now i see all
kinds of discussion downstream of what
elon musk has been saying about all of
the bots on twitter
i think i encounter a lot of sock
puppets that is to say there's a real
person there so it's not as simple as an
automated thing that can't quite pass an
elisa i mean it can't quite pass a
turing test
but
they're not real
right somebody
is shaping conversation right and people
are shaping conversation about me this
is one of the things i see is that there
are certain um
if i see a particularly nasty barbed
comment right very frequently almost all
the time i go to the bio i click on it
and it's like oh this person follows a
huge number of people compared to the
number a tiny number of people follows
them
right mostly their
their feed is retweets of things
sometimes they're things that i agree
with right so it's like it's designed to
cause people to
feel that this is actually somebody in
our sphere who thinks i'm an idiot right
anyway i don't know how big a sock
puppet problem we have but i know that
the fact that i i'm almost the only
person who's saying sock puppet why is
sock puppet not an important part of our
discussion about how much we are or are
not being manipulated right well it's
easier for me because it's been known
for a very long time that in russia
there are whole bot farms people get
paid to manipulate uh western discourse
and russian discourse of course and so
in in my space that's that's a very well
known
thing
of which i'm i'm aware and there's no
question that again that's a problem
that's going to have to be solved as
well
i come back to the printing press which
is
we are in a disruptive period in human
history
and we are going to have to have
solutions to these problems and i think
i'm going to focus on the ones that i
think i can make an impact on and you're
going to focus on the ones that you can
you think you can make an impact on and
that's how i think we make progress but
i am very concerned bret about the fact
that over the last
five or six years
we've all become experts in our minds on
things that we're not experts on and i i
do think that's a problem
i know i know you and i may sort of
disagree about where those delineation
lines go but
i think we've got to remember all of us
what we know and understand and also
what we don't know and don't understand
uh i am and how we
because you see the problem is like it's
the same with the mainstream media
people saying oh we need to rebuild
trust in the mainstream man i'm like no
no no we need a trustworthy mainstream
media and then we'll trust them again
and it's the same with medical experts
it's the same with all these things
we've got to we have the tools of
transparency now that we didn't have 20
years ago and i believe all that's
happened is we've now got a glance
at how corrupt these systems have been
since the beginning of time probably
um they've just become more complex and
therefore more corrupt in the complexity
of them i don't think human beings have
become more corrupt or there's become
more coercion has become more of that i
just think we see now what's been
happening this entire time and we've got
to upgrade our behavior to the level of
transparency that we now enjoy that's
what i think needs to happen i don't
think people are more corrupt than
they've been i agree with your argument
to that extent i think
we however have tools that amplify the
power of corrupt absolute system i mean
the system isn't more corrupt than a
corrupt dictatorship right we've seen
completely corrupt systems before but
the system the west becoming a corrupt
democracy simulation
is a problem i don't think it's becoming
that i think it's always been that
always yeah
yeah
um i don't think it's ever been
democratic i don't think it was nearly
this much of a fiction i believe we are
dealing i mean you know we literally
is joe biden president
uh what do you mean
we have a
an apparently
senile
person
who is ostensibly the go-to guy
if
the radar suggests that the russians
have launched
right
he's also apparently the guy
who decides whether or not we defend
taiwan if the chinese
invade and he can't keep straight what
our official policy is right
i don't think he's president do you
think that if we'd had the level of
insight into what happens in the heart
of government
that we have now that that level of
insight 40 50 60 80 100 150 years ago do
you think we would see more corruption
or less corruption
i think we would see much more effective
corruption currently now some of it is
very subtle and it is not illegal in
other words one of the things that
corruption does
is it enlarges its own capacity to wield
power
so you know it's a little bit of a hard
question to answer because the nature of
corruption has changed as the amount of
corruption has changed and it's you know
it's a little bit like um you know
saying how much is a dollar worth today
versus 100 years ago it's like well
which commodity hasn't changed its
utility to us
such that we are able to even answer the
question right right um
but i'm unpersuaded that
that you would see
in fact i'm quite persuaded that you
would see more corruption back then
well wait a second let's take it let's
take some place that i do know something
yeah okay
once upon a time in science
there wasn't really any point in
advancing
garbagey ideas oh sure no i'm talking
about politics well but politics and the
academy are not disconnected and so all
i'm saying is that if we if we pressure
test your idea someplace that we
actually can figure out whether you're
right or wrong i'm not saying you know
maybe that it's less corrupt than it was
over in other areas and it's more
corrupt than it was in academia and so
we could get it wrong but in academia
what we have is a system of incentives
that has changed and has you know caused
the
you know look in the era of gentleman
science and i'm not arguing that that
was the right way to do science right
democratizing science is a great thing
right but when you had people who were
financially secure doing science because
they loved it
there they were shooting for being right
in the long term right they weren't
shooting for getting employed in a job
market where there were 10 phds minted
for every
professorship so
i i think in academia i can tell you the
corruption is way way worse than it was
um i i think i can also tell you that
with respect to
um
pharma in particular the level of
corruption is
jaw-dropping
right and you know i'm not telling you
that you're in a position to know that
but i am telling you there are people
who have studied this question carefully
and
part of what i think threw us off in
covid was that
none of the architecture that got booted
up to persuade the government what to do
was new they were very good at it
they've been practicing for decades
so
anyway i see
new more aggressive and certainly more
effective mechanisms of corruption and i
also see that the cost of corruption is
that much greater because you know a
screw-up can
release a virus on the world that
spreads across it in weeks sure but i
was talking about politics so for
example just give you one example do you
think that 60 or 70 years ago in the
united states the links between
organized crime and the people who made
decisions about the direction of the
country was tighter or looser than it is
now
man i'm i'm upset at myself because uh
because i understand the rule you're
trying to lay down for yourself but
is pharma organized crime or not does it
count
well
not to me what i mean by organized crime
is mobsters why
would forget about that question let's
just focus on on on the mobs is the role
of mobsters greater or less much less
right so my point is there have been
forms of corruptions that are that have
largely gone extinct they have other
forms of corruption corruption that have
become more pronounced because the
problems of society have changed right
the problems that society is facing have
changed and therefore we focus on this
we have less focus on that my point is
i am unpersuaded by the argument that
things go on a broad scale have got
massively worse i think they're
different and i think we have much more
of an insight into how bad they've
always been
that's my argument
certainly in politics well i mean i i
see something in your style of argument
that i like i think it's useful right
basically
you take somebody who has a perspective
like me and you say
um
suppose i
account for what you see
with
this much less aggressive version of the
same observation
can you justify any of the delta between
our two positions and i agree it's
difficult right and it is a good
pressure test i like it um
my instinct is very much
uh
the nature of corruption has changed the
danger of corruption has changed the
tools that i mean i guess here's the
reason the power of anything has changed
because we are more powerful as human
beings i get it well no there's one
other aspect to it which uh i'm pretty
convinced
marshall's in my direction here
which is
there is always a competition between
those
morality is
effectively the willingness
to self-limit to not take advantage of
opportunities that you have for some
reason for some higher value okay
if we take people who are moral
they are inherently more constrained
okay
if we take people who are amoral they
have all the tools at their disposal
every single tool that the morally
constrained have plus whatever tools the
morally constrained won't use and so my
point is the greater the power of our
tools the greater the asymmetry between
the moral folks who are self-constrained
and those who will use every tool at
their disposal to accomplish their
objective
uh i quibble with part of that which is
it also increases the power of people
who are moral
uh but
my point is yes it increases that
disproportionately disproportionately
perhaps perhaps on some things maybe um
all i'm saying is i i think
we
you and i were talking about this before
we we started doing it on camera which
is the the sort of perpetual
philosophical argument between
conservatives and progressives and um
and i was telling you that somebody
introduced me to hayek's why i'm not a
conservative and his point was
essentially if conservatives want no
change and progressive ones must change
as possible the thing neither of them is
really addressing is the direction of
travel particularly conservatives
they're they struggle because they're
trying to stop change or slow change but
the direction of change is dictated by
the progressives
but in my opinion most of the change is
directed by technological and scientific
progress that we see that is
not party political in that sense so yes
the tools are becoming more powerful it
increases the power of the bad people it
also increases the power of the good
people and
if you look at the broader trend
i don't think we're in the worst place
now than we were a hundred years ago in
the 1920s
we i don't we are simultaneously in a
better and worst place
where's my argument we are we are in a
more dangerous place that's my argument
but if we were to right the ship at the
moment
you know we have what we need to make a
pretty good stable planet and that's my
argument my argument is
that we have the tools to make things a
lot better we have the tools to make
things a lot worse and all of us has a
role to play in using the tools that
make our lives better to improve it and
attempting to negate some of the
negative consequences and all of us are
going to do that in line with our own
values our own expertise our own
morality
but i am not persuaded that we are going
to hell in a hand basket
um
well i
i mean let me
just
defend my position my position is
any of us can see
that the
good governance
is not a dominant force
that we have reckless governance
and extremely dangerous tools whose
capacity to do harm is growing and so my
real point is
the technology is going to do us in
because
we are not paying attention to the fact
that we have to find let's put it this
way probably if we had great governance
we would still be doing
an okay but not wonderful job of
managing all the new hazards we're
creating it's not simple right even
really smart uncorrupt people are going
to have trouble figuring out where to
draw these lines
in the absence of that uncorrupted
structure managing these things
it's a ticking time bomb right and so my
my only point really is
we got to get to the the 18th century
tools aren't up to this challenge
they're not going to be able to do it
right the values
that were discovered and inscribed in
our founding documents
those things i believe were mostly right
and very insightful but the mechanisms
are too feeble and so we got to solve
that problem and
i think that means recognizing that
problem and that's dicey right because
in you know it's one of the things that
we have a hard time discussing because
of either the
inherent flaws of social media or the
sock puppeting of us all into false
beliefs or who knows
but i do think
it's um
it's urgent because
because the tech that will do us in is
growing
and
so like that
one more thing though on your point
about hayek which i didn't know that
hayek had made that argument it comes
close to actually the model that i use
which is why i call myself a progressive
i think we have to change radical change
is the only thing that can save us
but it's extremely dangerous right i'm
not enthusiastic about radical change i
just don't think we have a choice
that said
i
often say that i am a progressive who
wants to live in a world so good that i
get to be a conservative and one of the
things that i find missing from our
political landscape
is that people don't understand
conservatives often don't understand
that they
have a vital role to play preventing
progressives from excess
but that basically the question is well
how much
you know which problems are worth
solving which ones are we likely to make
worse you know it's a question of how
much leash to give us for progressivism
the conservatives have that role and
it's important and you're right it's not
a directional role right
um
but that
liberals
do not seem to understand that it's not
just simply good to be liberal right
that if you're headed somewhere and you
really believe that it's a place to be
then when you get there you gotta quit
right and no but that's the inevitable
problem with
progressives is
because they're utopians by the very
nature of their worldview they're
incapable of understanding that there's
a point where you need to stop
because until you reach utopia why would
you stop right we are going to this
beautiful place in the future
why would you stop 95 of the way there
that's the problem that's why they need
constraining by other people and and
you've also got to remember it's
a lot of this conversation is it's time
specific it's geography specific this is
why i don't understand anyone who has a
fixed ideological position it's like
saying bro you're driving a car what's
better do you speed up or slow down
well you got to know what else is going
on right so you've got to know what's
happening in society what are the
technological changes that are driving
what's happening and how do you respond
to those so right now for example
sitting here in the west i feel like the
pace of change is getting out of hand
and we're getting to a point where we're
introducing technologies and modes of
behavior and cultural innovations to
society
that
are coming too quickly
and that far too many of them are
untested as to their benefits
and many of them make me wary as to
their downsides right but if i'm sitting
in russia right now
i am a massive progressive i think that
society needs a lot of change
yeah 100 so so this is why these fixed
ideological positions in my opinion are
just
stupid frankly because
what you're saying is for the entirety
of the circumstances of my life
i'm gonna have the i need to slow down i
need to speed up position when when
you're driving on a road you need to be
able to
flex with what's happening around and
that's why i think in many ways the
cultural
war issues that we've got going on
they're kind of stupid in a way because
we're not engaging with the real issues
that we need to engage with and people
are too tribal to see the merits and in
the arguments of the other side for
example in this country we've got a
massive housing crisis which prevents
young people from buying house and
you've got conservatives running around
going oh yeah the people aren't having
enough kids people aren't there's no
family values in them well what did you
think was going to happen when you
prevented them from having a place to
live
right that's on you
it's not on progressive it's not
progressive capture of institutions that
have made young people into all of this
stuff or people complain on the
conservative side complain about hookup
culture or you think that just what just
progressives got a hold of universities
and now kids are having sex all the time
in this transactional way no that's a
product of technological revolution in
the 60s and technological revolution of
the internet and technological
revolution of the dating market right by
all those things caused by progressives
no they're technological so you have to
have a new form of responding to these
new challenges instead of going let's go
back to the 1950s right but
people don't want to play that game
because it's much more comfortable
playing the i am team blue iron team red
game and it does my head and it's
incredibly frustrating because instead
of looking for solutions we're now
looking for team allegiance which
probably we always have done anyway
right so that's the place i'm coming at
all this from what are the solutions
there are certain things i can advocate
for that i think will solve some of the
problems we're facing there's certain
influence i can bring to bear on some of
the people who make those decisions
there's a certain role in shaping the
conversation that i can play on the
issues that i understand well that's
what i'm going to do right and you've
got a role in doing that on other areas
and that's what you're going to do and
there are other people who will disagree
with us who have a role in doing that
and holding us to account and that's the
beautiful dance of the the free debate
that we have which we don't have in the
rest of the world and this is why i
wrote my book called an immigrants love
letter to the west because the west is
the only place we're actually able to do
that properly right i know there are
problems but we are still able to have
open conversations about stuff for now
you might argue about the things that
matter in most other places that's not
what's happening right in russia right
now every single independent media
outlet is shut down completely
completely shut down not censored not
prevented from being on this planet shut
down destroyed people fired people have
to flee the country so yes we've got
problems in the west but i think what
we've got to do is have a positive
vision of engaging with these problems
and part of that is i think people
engaging with the problems that they are
qualified to engage with that's why you
and i are having this discussion well
okay um
i agree with most of what you said i
certainly agree
with this issue about fixed political
positions it's mind-numbing you know i i
uh sometimes say
that conservatives are defending the
gains of
past liberals right i mean that's what
they do
um
so yeah fixed position is you know dead
on arrival
the
question of limiting yourself to that
which you're qualified to discuss is a
problem
let me just give you the following
again i'm going to resort to the
scientific place because i understand it
best
you might think somebody might tell you
if you want to make advancements in the
field the first thing to do is to learn
what the field understands about
everything and then when you've got that
under your belt you're qualified to make
progress
it's not how it works it's really not
how it works and in fact you'd be
surprised at how often the in the uh
history of science
breakthroughs actually come from outside
of a field and there's a reason for that
a field can talk itself into a
cul-de-sac and you have to be outside of
it in order to see what they're doing
wrong right and so those aren't the
experts in the field those are people
who can simply spot bad thinking so i
guess the point is i i first
want to disabuse you a little bit of the
idea of
the qualified
right lots of people who are nominally
qualified are not qualified and part of
what makes them unqualified can be
corruption
equally likely they may be unqualified
because they studied the right subject
but they don't have the right toolkit
for thinking about it in other words if
you're a biologist and you think like a
physicist
you're done
because the fact is complex systems
behave in a way that is not analogous
and so you know being able to think in
that way
is is vital
um i also think that there's an
interface between you know
who's qualified to talk about
um kovit right well is it people who
study
the host
is it people who study viruses generally
is it people who study epidemiological
uh patterns
is it people who study evolution is it
people who you know the point is
there are a lot of places to stand and
what you really want isn't i mean
the central part of your point i i agree
with all of you all of what you just
said the only point i'm making is
whatever the expertise of those people
and whether they're qualified to talk
about covert the one person who's
definitely not qualified to talk about
covet is a guy who studied politics and
economics and then did stand-up comedy
that's all i'm saying to you well
you know part of what happened i mean
covet is a political problem and the
political dimension of it i've been
talking about and will continue to talk
about as long as it's relevant right
right
look ultimately
i guess i would i would introduce the
idea this way
this is not the place to be talking
about
science this is not the place to sort
out the science that's my point well
but the problem is the place to do it is
in the universities and they're done
right the universities can't figure out
whether your child is male or female i
agree okay so the point is
the world of heterodox podcasts and
everything that surrounds it is the
equivalent of
the hills we are the rebels in the hills
who have fled the universities or in my
case been driven out by a crazed mob
um and we have gone somewhere else and
we are having those conversations and we
are having those conversations much more
broadly because the narrow things that
we would ordinarily be talking about
are actually connected to everything
else so
believe me i don't want you talking
about stuff you're really not qualified
to talk about but i also
know that there is a broader
conversation in which all of the people
who can still remember how to think are
talking about their quadrant and we
reach into each other's quadrants we
have to be very careful as we reach into
an area that we don't know something
about maybe our role there is to ask
questions here's what i don't understand
you're saying this but it doesn't add up
to me what am i missing so anyway i um
there aren't very many people out here
to do this well i
you know
you're a very good guy you've got a very
good mind
you have
broad expertise it doesn't extend to a
lot of other stuff but
you know in the broader conversation do
i want you drawing hard and fast lines
about where you're allowed to you know
ask a question or voice an opinion no
because none of this should be sensitive
to that the fact is unfortunately
this mechanism hashing stuff out it's
how it's how we come to think it's us
collectively thinking so great i agree
but um
i agree completely and
all i'm saying is i think it would be
better
if you had this conversation with
another scientist
who with whom you could have this
conversation in the way that you're no
longer able to do in a university and
that's the way that it was done i think
that's really important but and the
reason i'm saying all of this and the
reason i'm being so resistant to to what
you're saying to some extent is
you remember how you talked about
modeling certain behavior this is what i
am modeling at least i'm trying to
you know how you talk about crossing
over from your field of expertise to
others and whatever
i think we do too much of that now
that's my opinion but people may
disagree uh but i see
i i saw a little bit with covered i saw
some people going off the deep end in my
opinion on it people who are not
qualified suddenly they've got an
opinion about whether this particular
drug works or whether this particular
form of
or whatever i see it now with ukraine
i'm sure i'll see with lots of other
things
the
the dopamine
here from the likes on the twitters and
the facebooks and whatever is so
powerful
that many many people are now addicted
to having the hot take that their tribe
expects them or wants them to have
phrased in the right way with the right
amount of sarcasm and humor and
destruction with facts and logic and
whatever of the other team
that
they are now moving into that field and
i
i think that's bad
i think it's dangerous and i am trying
to model not doing that that's what i'm
trying to do here and i'm trying to say
to people yes you've got 50 000 twitter
followers yes you've got a hundred
thousand does not mean that you know
we're talking about and i say that first
and foremost about myself right
uh i i actually think if more of us
model that we'd have a healthier online
conversation
well i think the irony is
we were doing it right idw was a
prototype of exactly that and i have
become fond of the idea that idw was
effectively a protocol
i do think it was a prototype i do think
it is vital and that
effectively we need it back because um
it sort of went
silent
it divided over covered
well it was understood to be a group of
people
and because it was understood to be a
group of people when that group of
people could not have a civil
conversation
it wasn't a thing and
it needs to be a thing whatever idw is
we need to be able to have difficult
conversations across any of these lines
and not
make it personal
and
so anyway i hope it returns
i don't see another way forward because
again i think that you know we are the
rebels in the hills and the rebels in
the hills are going to have to
descend from the hills and impose some
kind of
reasonable standard on how we govern
ourselves because the people who are
governing us now are incapable of doing
it well right
we're going to have to point the way
um
and
in any case yeah we i guess you know
i think what we've established here
is that there is
that we have not
ourselves all figured out exactly we
have not been explicit with ourselves
about where we will go where we won't go
why we will you know transcripts the
transgress this line and not that line
and we probably should right we should
you know i have a favorite line
uh from did you ever watch the wire oh
i'm a massive fan of the massive fan of
the wire okay omar little at some point
has been uh
little yeah he's been uh arrested for a
murder he did not commit and he is
attempting to persuade
um
yeah he's attempting to persuade bunk
that he
wouldn't have committed this murder
despite the fact that he freely admits
that he's committed many and he says a
man's got to have a code yeah he says
you know i didn't do this because it
violates my code that's what his point
is and
so i think the thing is we all do need
to have a code and
what's more we need to know what it is
so that we know when we're in danger of
violating it yeah
and
check
if i'm wrong about this but my
prediction
for this conversation when you put it
out is a lot of people will be extremely
dissatisfied with it
because
we all want a hot take now
we all want certainty and we all want a
hot take and we all want a guy who's got
an opinion and it matches what we
already believe and we've become very
uncomfortable with uncertainty
um we probably always were to be fair
and so
that's i think a really important
thing going forward for me in terms of
my code
is not having false certainty about
things about which i'm not actually
certain
because it's incentivized by the
mechanisms that we're using to put this
conversation out well this is a um a
perfect note to end on because i'm going
to predict the exact opposite and here's
why
um
in my
world as i travel around it
i find that there is a
bizarre but i've i think it's delightful
a hunger
for
um
disagreement amongst people who clearly
like each other right that when
people hear others disagree and it
doesn't make them angry and they
actually work to understand what is
being said rather than to you know
[Music]
take a cheap shot that is funny or
whatever
um they gravitate to it and because i
think it's so rare right that ten this
tribal tendency is so strong that people
just fall into it even people who in
principle know better
and
so anyway my guess is going to be
that people will really appreciate the
fact that you and i didn't agree and
didn't reach agreement exactly but
clearly hurt each other so anyway um and
now we've we've muddled the experiment
of course by putting our predictions on
the line
wondering if there's a way we could
rescue it by
editing that off
well i will say um
to those of you who are watching if you
are going to make a comment
it is certainly not scientific at this
point the experiment is unblinded but if
you can try to remember what you thought
about the conversation before we
discussed what you might think about the
conversation and if there is a delta
between those two if your mind has been
changed by something we have said in
this very tail end then say so right
yeah i liked the conversation until or i
didn't like it until um let us know
all right
constantine kissing it has been an
absolute pleasure um i am so thrilled to
be sitting with you in person i hope it
isn't long before we do this again
um on one side of the pond or the other
i look forward to my friend all right um
your book an immigrant's love letter to
the west now on july 14th out on july
14th very much looking forward to that
people can find you on twitter
at constantin kitchen and trigonometry
of course i'm trying to country of
course we've been
advertising subtly for you the whole
time all right wonderful well thanks so
much thanks for coming along
[Music]